there's some pretty weird symptoms
associated with the vitamin D deficiency
that I'd like to share with you but
maybe I should have used a better word
than weird symptoms these are symptoms
that you wouldn't think are associated
with a vitamin D deficiency and there's
research behind each one and I'm going
to put all that information down below
as you probably already know vitamin D
is so important and I think most people
do know it's associated with bone loss
bone pain low immune system depression
high blood pressure more inflam
if you're deficient asthma especially in
children as well as poor sleep but there
are 23 additional symptoms that you
probably had no idea were connected to a
vitamin D deficiency let's go through
them so nightmares now typically
nightmares are related to a vitamin B1
deficiency but a vitamin D deficiency
can also produce the manifestation of a
nightmare uh number two restless leg
syndrome this too is usually a B1
deficiency because someone's consuming
too many carbohydrates but it can also
be a vitamin D deficiency as well and
interestingly enough I used to have
restless leg syndrome and probably
because of all the sugar I was eating
was not only depleting vitamin B1 but
vitamin D as well and then number three
we have acne the sebaceous clan that is
involved in uh acne especially if it's
inflamed or causing some type of
obstruction so the oil can't get out of
this gland could also easily stem from a
vitamin D deficiency number four bipolar
there's been quite a few studies related
to someone having bipolar and nearly
they're always deficient in vitamin D
and we know how important vitamin D is
in mood disorders especially depression
and other mood disorders including
bipolar uh number five is a skipped
heartbeat okay because of the direct
connection with the vitamin D deficiency
and what it can do to the heart but it
can definitely affect the pacemaker of
the heart so you can start off having
like a Skip Beat and then palpitation
and maybe even worse develop even
arhythmia okay and even atrial
fibrillation there's also certain
breathing uh disorders related to a
vitamin D deficiency that go beyond just
asthma but as you might know like a lot
of pneumonia and lung infections are
related to a vitamin D deficiency
because of the immune system being weak
and then making you susceptible to
viruses but
wheezing is definitely a symptom of a
vitamin D deficiency if you have a child
a newborn that is wheezing or making
this weird breathing sound suspect of
vitamin D deficiency in fact anything
related to breathing including sleep
apnea make sure that person is getting
enough vitamin D now skin disorders are
another big one especially psoriasis and
eczema now psoriasis is an autoimmune
problem and any autoimmune problem is
usually involving the immune system and
a vitamin D deficiency associated with
that in fact that's the best remedy for
any autoimmune problem is taking larger
amounts of vitamin D3 at least 50,000
IUS I would also add in there uh making
sure that the person is eating very very
clean like with the healthy keto and
doing a lot of intermittent fasting
because the problem with autoimmune is
inflammation so if you want to reduce
inflammation vitamin D and fasting are
the two most important things another
thing that's related to a vitamin D
deficiency is
sinus issues especially in children give
them more vitamin D or get them exposed
to the sun hay fever in adults and
children is associated with a vitamin D
deficiency if your infant has this rapid
breathing okay and I already mentioned
breathing with wheezing but a rapid
breathing situation suspect a vitamin D
deficiency and one of the challenges if
a mother is breastfeeding the infant
there's not usually a lot of vitamin D
in in breast milk unless that mother is
getting more sun or taking vitamin D or
consuming Foods higher in vitamin D
vitamin D is a very common deficiency
with women who are uh carrying um a baby
as well as um when they're breastfeeding
because of how much the body is being
tapped into the reserves um when feeding
uh the child breast milk so vitamin D is
so important in your prenatal as well as
during your period of time of of um
breastfeeding um this next one is
interesting because it's also associated
with a lot of children that have
recurrent tonsilitis or very enlarged
tonsils give them more vitamin D and
there are certain types of vitamin D
that come in a liquid that you can use
that are easy to give it a small infant
or a child just put it in their um
liquids and then another one that's
associated with children is structural
developmental problems so I'm talking
about flat feet Bode legs
scoliosis kyphosis which is
Hunchback or suede back which is uh a
lordosis uh Dental
malformations with the maxillary bone up
to here if the child's Jaws are not
correct or there's an overbite or an
underbite or there's just some problem
with the teeth that you need a dentist
to correct an orthodontist to correct
suspect a vitamin D def deficiency
number 13 long Coit where a person has
fatigue that can be either a B1
deficiency or a vitamin D deficiency
number 14 early puberty you have this
early development that shouldn't be
happening at a certain age suspect a
vitamin D deficiency now that's also
associated with certain endocrine
disruptors in the environment uh
chemicals in the environment but that's
for a different video number 15 uterine
fibroids apparently in one study uh
these fibroids were halted or stopped
when the group consumed 50,000 IUS of
vitamin D3 here's another one irregular
menstrual cycles now who doesn't have a
problem with that a female is
13.3 times more likely to have irregular
menstrual cycles when they are deficient
in vitamin D a longer cycle is also
associated with a low vitamin D there's
a 7.8 times more likelihood for that
cycle to go longer if there is deficient
vitamin D urinary incontinence three
times more likely if you're deficient in
vitamin D uh there was one study in
older um black women that related to
this and they also noted that the group
that took like 2,000 IUS of vitamin D3
didn't see any Improvement in this
urinary problem so you have to take more
at least 10,000 I use vertigo is also
associated with a low vitamin D because
a certain type of vertigo is really a
calcium Crystal building up on the
inside of your ear and that's
interfering with the little hairs that
are associated with your equilibrium and
taking enough vitamin D can help um
prevent that but you also have to take
vitamin K2 as well in fact anytime you
take vitamin D3 also at the same time
take vitamin K2 at a ratio of 10,000
iuse of vitamin D3 to a 100 microgram of
vitamin K2 sarcopenia that is a problem
of muscle loss as someone ages you're
7.7 times more likely to develop
sarcopenia if you're low in vitamin D3
myopia usually happens when we are
exposed to Too Much screen time looking
at the computer and not getting enough
actual Sun but there's definitely an
association between that condition and
low vitamin D gloma okay that's pressure
built up in the eye apparently you're U
twice as likely to get glucoma if you're
low in vitamin D3 and then we have
number 23 erectile dysfunction you're
apparently 1.3 times more likely to
develop this if you're low in vitamin D3
of course there's many other factors but
I'm just talking about the association
between low vitamin D and all of these
other conditions now because of the
censoring and the suppressing of the
algorithms on YouTube it's becoming more
difficult to find my content and there's
a lot of content that I cannot put on
YouTube unfortunately so to make sure
you have full access of all my
information go to drberg.com And
subscribe to my newsletter by clicking
the link Down Below in the description I
will see you on the other side now I've
done a lot of videos on vitamin D if you
have not seen this very popular video on
vitamin D3 I think you'll enjoy it I put
it up right here check it
out